[Musique]
s'il est un insecte vit son casque à si
c'était une infirmité une infirmité à
lomé théâtre comme si tu étais un
matelas
c'était une perversion toi c'était un
dictateur tube toi si tu étais un poison
c'est moi signe ah c'était une guerre
3 je sais pas si c'était une arme et
larmes alors je voulais c'était un
accident un accident d'avion dans ce cas
là c'est pas
anvers qui cassent pas ce qu'ils ont dit
que ça porte bonheur et si tu étais une
sicafi une cicatrice à nay alors n'est
pas refermée les regarde un supplice
la critique mais c'est le cocon cet été
une injure colère très bio langue comme
ça tu déclares et d'un seul coup qui
durerait longtemps quand même
je ne sais pas vraiment rancunier mais
j'ai beaucoup de patientes c'était une
maladie
contre
je sais très bien que tout ce qui
explique qu'il fait très mal
de gros bourdon année 700 ce serait qui
pendant 2 pourquoi parce que les autres
ouais vous faites tous les deux reprises
et fait que les femmes pendant ces sur
ma balle je les exploitent une façon
insolite c'est clair si tu étais un
dictateur c'est un dictateur frédéric ii
le plus coûteux si c'était un vice mais
une vie c'est pas un jour négatif
si tu étais une guerre dans mon métier
évidemment une guerre avant tfm et wifi
un poison c'est très je serai un poison
je suis bloqué alors on va baisser la
lumière vous inquiétez pas question mais
ces lignes on bouge pas
[Musique]
voilà je vous faire tirer le portrait
chinois me colle ici le portrait chinois
mais les chinois c'est si tu étais une
fleur jeu sera un mot le myosotis si
j'étais un homme politique je serai
michel bulté tout ça moi je vous fais un
anti portrait chinois si vous étiez un
défaut sur ye quoi comme défaut d'avoir
beaucoup de difficultés
j'ai pas la décision ah oui voilà si
vous étiez une maladie une maladie se
serait forcément une maladie 201 oui je
dis c'est un dictateur à bas ce serait
une claire forcément sujet tient à vis
la vertu bonne réponse vous étiez un
supplice la conversation
si vous étiez une humiliation si j'étais
une humiliation d'estrées victimes qu'on
me dise que je suis une victime et une
infirmité pour finir je vous est il une
infirmité qu'alain termites et seriez
vous un bain
je suis une infirme alors jean marie est
ce que tu connais le portrait chinois de
prendre à chênois non semaine dernière
je connais le proverbe dit moi un
proverbe chinois programme chinois les
chinois sont très forts tuer ben quoi
chinois ils disent ils une de perdue
une de perdue c'est clair ici tout le
temps pas de nouvelles pas de nouvelles
jaillissent toujours il faut pas vendre
la peau de l'ours non pas la grande
femme à lunettes femme à lunettes si tu
veux tu peux pas lutter je veux dire ses
efforts rien ne sert de courir
ça sert à rien donc sa levée respecte
beaucoup pour ça c'est tout l'air le
portrait chinois si tu veux c'est
définir la personnalité de quelqu'un à
travers la question style s'il était une
fleur par exemple là c'était une pure
tuerie quoi toi comme horreur c'est une
rose - comme ça ouais tu vois c'est
qu'on voit bien que j'ai un bon salaire
nous personne du bon alors nous ici on
fait lentilles portrait chinois ce
qu'ils étaient une injure
[ __ ] je vais garder mon dans l'armée
maintenant ça va ils marchent bien en ce
moment c'est comme voir et ça va être
coller au cul comme s'il était un
accident
je serai un accident de chasse
moi ça me fait ça me ferait bien marrer
vous mais j'aime bien que 10 tirs un peu
entre se changer un peu michel droite ça
fait un peu de répit aux bestiaux tu
connais la blague des de deux chasseurs
qui cassent la croûte ils ont posé leurs
fusils sur un arbre bien des deux fusils
qui glisse pillent 1d 2d des chasseurs
et ce pour les deux décharges de
chevrotine en pleine gueule il est biffé
cacher puis son pote il se retourne il
volait bas il dit en fait une tête il
moi aussi j'ai eu peur
bien des chasseurs si tu étais un
collabo inca d'abord la bague je vois en
deuxième division
il était un bouton gros boutons un gros
bouton ouais je serai quoique déjà un
groupe un gros bouton ce sur la gueule
de mylène farmer
c'est une cicatrice
c'est beaucoup les femmes belges à
l'heure elles s'endorment tu joues avec
un doigt dans la choupinette nar parce
qu'elles ont peur que sa cicatrice qui
j'étais un [ __ ] je serai thierry
ardisson et c'était un travesti je suis
peut-être une meilleure robert bardot
qui me demande est ce que tu connais le
portrait chinois le portrait chinois
jeudi par exemple s'il était une fleur
quelles fleurs tu serais marijuana c'est
le piège
donc je vais pas répondre donc c'est
l'anti portrait chinois et des femmes
j'y répondrai pas quand tu vas répondre
si tu étais un défaut un défaut way a
redit son temps
fassi s'est pas passé comme un joker tu
peux le faire qu'une fois
oui eh ben je vais l'employé qu'une fois
à la gare de ces faits j'étais une
maladie une maladie nerveuse tient une
maladie nerveuse well as petites
maladies psychosomatiques qu'il donne
des plaques avant le rendez vous
important
ah ouais historienne et surtout le toit
le monde 8 la mauvaise plaques
je viens pour chercher du job d'un
rendez vous avec une fille et moi je me
manifeste et tu sais pas comment me
soigner parce que c'est en toi la
solution la maladie de timsit way un
nerveux verve un insecte un insecte un
empire en petits morceaux et pas
n'importe où le morpion dans une petite
forêt vierge comme ça d'une femme du
monde comme ça je dirais tout le monde
mais à toute la série les journalistes
notamment clock je peux changer de
personnes comme ça un microbe un microbe
pas j'ai pas de dire le gonocoque dira
peut-être tiens y'a un microbe ce n'est
pas son nom mais il se passe par la
salive et c'est la maladie de l'amour tu
sais que ça te donne un manque de
globules blancs comme seul on dit ah
vous avez embrassé les pales sida non
c'est la salle email urines jugement
tout comme celle là oui ça toi c'est la
mono est vrai il y en a un qui lui va
a aussi connu en mononucléose les
[ __ ] chercher sans n'ont pas d'accord
on est bien entouré et le produit qui me
l'a t-il s'il détient un dictateur avec
mademoiselle je veux bien un dictateur
vrai peut-être rêvé d'être andy hallett
tout le monde se lève pour que tu
supportes way gt1 vis à vis de plus oui
c'est trop je veux pas je veux pas un
impôt un impôt sur les coûts le [ __ ]
j'en ai de l'oseille on renfloue les
caisses de l'état tu me dois 300 bars
depuis le début et moi aussi je suis le
premier à payer 150
c'était un [ __ ] un homme politique qui
respecte pas le jeu qui pense à lui
avant de penser à la nation ça c'est un
[ __ ] pas tous ses biens sa pommette
car l'on mette à vue dès fois je compte
des froids mais moins à temps il ya
quelqu'un là on m'a soufflé arrive en
général c'est tout seul chez moi mais là
il est tard aux folies bergères je me
sens un peu chez moi un bouton celui que
tu as sur le front il fait mal c'est un
supplice un supplice je peux pas
répondre à redescendre à jaïpur de
hockey tellement tu vois joker la chèvre
suppute vermandel en premier ma mère me
le fait déjeuner débat
un point devant un poison celui que tu
as dans le vert la halle au top si on va
te dire une infirmité n'infirme le nez
en trompette et bah oui je me suis et
attention c'est un faux nez moi à oui je
me suis fait refaire le même si c'était
un assassin que tu souhaites l'assassin
eliot ness à sa 8ème et a vu le nombre
de make it be gone too late épisode il
fait partie de la politique
ah ouais eliot ness et si tu étais un
fait eliot ness je serais dit tu devrais
pas être là ma fille non je le connais
en voyou laurent batsch ai jamais vu en
flic va fait non mais je demande à voir
[Musique]
alors le portrait chinois vous
connaissez ces sites étaient une fleur
je serai aux autistes lentilles portrait
chinois celle inverse si vous étiez un
défaut christophe alévêque j'étais un
défaut à notre époque
des fois notre époque l'honnêteté si
vous étiez une maladie l'amour c'est une
perversion dernière sion un savon
pommeau de douche on se trouve que l'on
sache trop à l'hygiène en général mais
si vous étiez une guerre mariage pas mal
à si vous étiez un vice si j'étais
indices je serai rouillé une arme bon
armes une arme je sois une belle
gonzesse un supplice supplice si je
serai une page de pub pendant le film un
poison raisons sont à big mac un [ __ ]
si j'étais un [ __ ] je serai riche si
vous étiez un dictateur si j'étais un
dictateur je serai le bon dieu si vous
étiez un assassin c'est une façon
c'est un assassin je serai veuf j'étais
sûr qu'il était une banque lyon pour
l'emporter si vous étiez à microbes
c'est un microbe ce serait dans ton nez
un terroriste s'est enrichie tard
terroriste en ce moment j'aurais du
boulot je reproche aux mages way
l'humiliation une paire de faire deux
cuisses qui ne veut pas s'ouvrir
je vous étiez de bord je serai peur
est-ce que tu connais le portrait
chinois de réputation or par exemple se
disent ils étaient une fleur quelles
fleurs tu serais absolument à nous ici
on fait un truc un peu plus pervers sans
blague
c'est l'anti portrait chinois si c'était
une injure
vanessa paradis
[Rires]
ça va comme réponse était un accident
cardiaque
c'était un insecte qui adore les baies
de goji
[Musique]
c'est un microbe et mikron sait quel
genre de microbes
jean-louis micro de jean louis frot le
fait à lui alors si tu étais un microbe
unanime
ouais pourquoi parce que ça résiste bien
et dans les temps dans les mauvais
moments seront fermés mardi
vingt ans après ça recommence à te
servir le cas de le dire il faut c'est
pas mal à toi s'il était un dictateur
répond pas michel blanc hirsch
en deux mots
camus dimanche un dictateur mon père
pour le psychanalyste ballon c'est une
panne ou pas
bah voilà ah c'est sûr tu vas répondre
quoi tu connection les couteaux c'est ce
que ça signifie un bon père maladie une
fois mais je pense que ça mais depuis
que c'est un couteau pour un
psychanalyste ce serait pareil pourquoi
cette fois c'est un couteau chez fox
non mais t'as des nerfs de t'avoir belge
pas été dit que c'était un symbolique du
sexe de l'homme voilà tu y crois ça non
elle croit pas au sexe de l'homme
c'était à toi si c'était un chômeur moi
je serai bien emmerdé talent était
chômeur quoi oui ça toucher les assedic
way chômeurs j'ai été malheureux
ouais ça moi je peux passer des médecins
n'ont alors là tu as fait chez pas
combien de temps je sais moi c'est
important parce que ils m'ont donné à
moi tu appelleras va évidemment un
cette gêne pas de prendre je sais pas
200 briques offert celui de soirée et
après toucher les assedic pendant un an
non franchement c'est d'ailleurs ce qui
me gêne c'est de donner 60 % aux impôts
sur les 200 briques ensuite mis sur les
40 % qui restent devenait beaucoup pour
les assedic ensuite lorsque me reversent
les assedic d'ordonner 60% aux impôts
ouais ça ça me gêne beaucoup mais on ne
regrette pas non pas du tout mais quand
je donne 60 % impôts je ne pense pas je
ne demande pas qu'on me traite de sale
jeu j'espère que quand je touche ce à
quoi j'ai droit on
on peut me [ __ ] la paix par le traité
de [ __ ] d'accord ou alors sinon faut
tout remettre à plat rend ça va c'est la
cité était un professeur de danse de
danse c'est qu'il a fait aux yeux de
prof de piano c'est qu'ils jouent très
bien du piano ne peuvent pas prof pas
prêtes à payer de concertiste enfin j'ai
failli j'ai pas été concertés oui moi
j'ai failli être gagnant de la
république aussi on aime ce que je fais
toi tu as failli faire du trapèze c'est
ça hein
et c'est pourquoi vous êtes à laisser
tomber non vous n'avez pas peur c'est
plus compliqué de faire ce que tu fais
aujourd'hui annoncé papa je me serais
bien tenté à bon ouais un jour sur la
moquette de coco jeunes québécois je me
suis il raflait tout lasse non mais je
voulais faire du trapèze et puis je me
suis présenté à l'école du cirque quand
j'avais 8 ans on m'a dit qu'il fallait
attendre d'avoir dix ans alors entre les
deux j'étais impatient de changer dit on
à vous
[Musique]
n'améliore pas fait vous pouvez venir
quand vous voulez parce que vous ne
bougez pas dans le jingle site entre en
vigueur d'ici c'est avec nos amis il
faut le savoir quand elle rencontre un
homme pour la première fois il faut la
regarder dans les yeux sinon c'est même
pas la peine de la gare datant de mai
nouveau se connaissaient depuis
longtemps et je regardais ces petits
mots qu'est ce que vous pensez des alors
philippe geluck vous connaissez le
portrait chinois
oui le portrait chinois c'est si tu
étais une fleur quelles fleurs serais-tu
bon l'an petit portrait chinois c'est
plus compliqué si vous étiez une injure
ce serait gros cons ah oui parce que
gros con c'est vraiment bien c'est que
pour être un gros con il faut pas être
gros ouais il suffit d'être qu'on a
c'est vrai ça al'avantage ça fait un bon
match
belinda vous suivez là en tout à fait là
la commanderie gros coup en anglais
alors est bon se poser la question
précisément mais on s'est dit texto
pichichi tsébo sujet jim maladie la
maladie parkinson
parce que ça me permettrait de continuer
à jouer des maracas et puis désigné pour
le tout
si vous étiez un accident en art on part
d'accidents heureux un peintre dont le
pinceau dérape crée parfois une tâche
magnifique
vous étiez une perversion je crois que
je suis une perversion une guerre un
coin un conflit nucléaire mondial ça
résoudrait pas mal de problèmes c'est
sur le réchauffement de la terre à se
régler au moins si vous étiez indices le
vis sans fin
inventé par michel-ange une trahison
vous savez je suis quelqu'un de fidèle
en amitié dans le travail et dans la vie
ce serait peut-être de vous révéler des
secrets touchant michel drucker à michel
drucker et son chien
oui parce que je les vois parfois dans
le bureau et je sais qui prend les
véritables décisions si vous étiez vous
étiez une arme un canon pourrez toujours
rêvé d'être un canon de labeur en face
d'eux mais oui c'est il dit flight en
transmettent une fille est très jolie on
dit c'est un canon un canon belinda
tacheté merci oui bien sûr s'il tourne à
une cicatrice si vous étiez une
cicatrice le sourire
une cicatrice qui ne se referment jamais
à la bataille et ses bons amis
il est trop fort si vous étiez un [ __ ]
vous
[Applaudissements]
c'est rare que je poussais si vous était
un dictateur
on peut pas dire vous l'avez dit une
fois le maître du monde
ouais oui parce que je fais pas les
choses à moitié
oui donc maîtres du monde ou rien maître
du monde aurait ainsi vous étiez une
infirmité la calvitie
oui parce que ça va c'est l'infirmité
qui a des avantages de même c'est pas
douloureux oui c'est vrai ça fait gagner
du temps le matin pour se coiffer et
puis ça rend tellement cette vision et
c'est vrai vous en tous les cas c'est
vachement gassama pas permis à l'homme
chauve ça vous ça vous fait fuir non ça
me fait rire père est complètement
chauve bien et ben voilà c'est parce que
je suis passé à son johnny campbell
les compères et donc mariage ne va pas
donc à glee ce qui ne veut pas enlever
des eaux et son château et quand j'avais
4 ans l'aéroport il a je lui enlever son
chapeau j'étais très noir si vous étiez
un microbe la grippe
ouais vous vous tombez vous êtes
microbes et vous avez la possibilité de
donner la grippe
je sais pas au chanteur carlos ou à
naomi campbell
n'hésitez pas à huy ah bah non clair
vous choisissez carlos dias
si vous étiez nasa regard si vous étiez
un terroriste carlos
vous étiez une culture une torture oui
tortues ninja oui c'est vrai que ça va
aller il est court il est con c'est bien
ce que j'allais dire zoé la torture soit
rapide
si vous étiez une humiliation dans sa
marche pas comme un court a pas arrivé à
son avis que l'humiliation
réponse en même temps et si vous étiez
une mort la petite mort à
[Musique]
c'est une rupture a pas de livry
structure d'anévrisme si rapide une
injure vanille qu'il comptait mort qui
tâche il a souvent pris au mot dite des
'quatre certains dix mille et une
maladie incurable de toute chose de vrai
dans la grippe parce que ça met les gens
à plein un accident travail bien sûr
vrai donc c'est donc une perversion à se
parler de soi même à la troisième
personne
ah oui comme alain delon de nanisme de
la pluie il ya des plombes dit aussi
qu'elle monsieur bah oui mais ils disent
comme ça comment il va et j'adore un
vice par l'alcool les femmes ça va
ensemble non une arme un pistolet ou un
supplice
je ne ferai plus de chinois mais le
monopoly
[Rires]
moi j'aime répondu l'astrologie moi mais
ça je suis miss à tous les jours
maintenant c'est ça devient une routine
si vous étiez un dictateur je serai
metteur en scène vous étiez une torture
la torture jean pierre foucault
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
donc vous connaissez le portrait chinois
si j'étais une fleur je serai au mieux
aux petits bon ça c'est l'anti portrait
chinois par exemple si vous étiez une
injure
il a une très belle dans full fair loft
sam shepard cber moi pas de ta mère
d'accord si vous étiez une maladie
latifi si vous étiez un accident une
rupture d'anévrisme
parce que ça arrive brutalement comme ça
ça manque c'est dans mes interne une
perversion
se ronger les ongles je vous étiez une
guerre à une garce éviter une révolution
vous étiez avis le voyeurisme
justin trahison l'adultère une arme une
arme blanche supplice les supplices
défend morceau c'est quoi via une photo
dont les larmes d'eros de bataille avec
un chinois est découpé en morceaux et on
va son regard quasi vous êtes découvert
bataille l'âge de 15 ans way et dans
viande c'est dans dix ans nous il ya pis
alors j'ai dit les dédier à pied
angélique c'est ça sweeting cicatrices
si vous étiez un poison la digitaline ce
que gilbert suicider avec la digital y
est et il en faut 60 votes pour mourir
donc au moins je sais si vous étiez une
[ __ ]
voilà non j'hésite entre lady macbeth et
monica levinsky que les deux annaba
merritt fait du mal pour rien si vous
n'êtes jamais impôts de droits de
succession
si vous étiez une table ne pas savoir
répondre à une de vos questions
un dictateur dieu une infirmité
l'incontinence nasa
sid ahmed vall 1 j'ai écrit une pièce
sur lui avant si vous étiez à microbes à
colibacilles si vous étiez un terroriste
je sais pas encore ce qu'on avait
quelqu'un devant oyonnax toutes les
semaines ça n'existe pas encore s'ils
étaient en vacances le mois dernier
ouais j'en ai pas vus 0 il se cache
c'est normal c'est ma théorie est active
au collège instant dans un aéroport
si vous étiez une torture l'heure les
chatouille ah bon je vous étiez m'bour
un crime passionnel
alors j'ai une petite interview pour toi
plus que le sujet il était réservé pour
toi un homme jean thubert portrait
chinois le portrait chinois c'est quand
on dit à quelqu'un s'il était une fleur
quelles fleurs plus peur de toi c'est
très con alors moi j'étais préparé une
petite interview spéciale c'est l'anti
portrait chinois si tu étais une injure
le pen trop c'était un collabo le pen
ouais
si c'était une maladie open l'a loupé
dit elle à l'oeuf et n'utiliser d'un
accident enfin je tire bois ouais
si tu étais un insecte j'aimerais un
truc un moustique
oui c'est ce que je fais est sûre enfin
ou même qui transporte du maladie un
pire que tout elle est une perversion du
srec wacom perversion catholique
c'était une arme crayon était un bouton
de brian c'était un supplice supplice de
lire le présent
ouais c'est un raciste toujours pareil
jean-marie mais si tu étais un immigré
mon fils c'est sous le toit
[Musique]
transfert le ter si vous étiez un défaut
vous soyez quels défauts je je je suis
myope ça c'est à dire c'est formidable
quand on aime bien vous êtes dans la
même pièce que didier schuller et vous
le voyez pas ça peut aider
si vous étiez un accident un accident
naturel peut-être j'ai rêvé d'être un
raz-de-marée est ce que la mère ou du
foetus l aval est tellement de choses
qu'un quelques ex revanche si vous étiez
une perversion de voyeur le voyeurisme
j'aimerais bien rentrer voir les gens
comme ça comment il dans la tête
wei dans leur tête mais aussi de chez
eux ça j'adore rsa une bouche si vous
étiez une guerre la norme en effet
débarquement en normandie
ça c'était il y avait des français qui
débarque en lomagne et des fusilliers
marins qui ont débarqué en normandie
les premiers les premiers sur la plage
de
riva bella et beaucoup sont morts
j'arrête là c'était très beau si c'est
une arme un opinel ou un truc comme ça
pour le figa tels couteaux corse alors
un supplice il ya un très beau supplice
que que j'ai en tête qui est celui de
tantale mais il est dans l'eau et puis
l'eau arrive jusque là il a soif
ouais je propose qu'on replace le par
dudu vendront d'année ou par un petrus
d'un très bon bordeaux
c'est une cicatrice je vais pas vous la
montrer mais je suis ouvert de la jusque
là bah oui c'est la mienne j'aime bien
je la touche
ah oui à tout si vous êtes c'est une
[ __ ] vous seriez qui moi je me pose
moi parce que j'ai jamais dit ça une
femme mais bon dommage chacun son truc
mais j'ai jamais dit ça il fane jamais
ne s'est pas chacun son truc c'est on
est tous comme ça en temps normal
voilà je pensais je pensais à simone
signoret dans les diaboliques non avec
papa la personne personnages ou madame
de merteuil dans l oms dangereux je
viens une femme qui fait des trucs
extraordinaires amants diaboliques
mais qui arrive à faire un certain tué
son amant par la maîtresse de 7 à mon
sujet si vous étiez un dictateur quel
dictateur seriez-vous je n'aime pas ça
je pensais me salis charlie chaplin
quand il joue avec un ballon
il s'appelle une dictature mais oui avec
un bal auquel le monde c'est pas drôle
si vous êtes j'aurais voulu que l'on
pose ces questions là ah non on peut
déposer sa mort est la poser à toi la
prochaine si vous étiez une torture 1,18
à tête avec la reine d'angleterre
ah oui
c'est les oreilles si vous étiez une
torture moi je m'appellerai sodomites ou
alors si j'étais une torture je
m'appellerai cocaïne par exemple voilà
ça c'est une vraie réponse c'est pour ça
qu'il ya des questions à bois de tout à
l'heure la voilà un dictateur ou autres
mecs qui avaient envie de jouer là si
vous étiez un terroriste ou seriez qui
comme terroriste un mec qui roule en
ferrari qui s'arrête pas quand vous
étiez nature vous seriez quelle injure
on va manger la culotte atteint vieille
hills est il qu'hier version g star
gesta en forme et vous êtes en forme là
si vous étiez à vis à vis 1 clis je
dirais comme ils s'appellent l'autre
était michael youn ouais parce que
quelque part ça va vite si le morning
live sur m6 tous les matins mais c'est
même pas pour lui faire quoi que ce soit
si je suis pas démago moi c'est vraiment
parce que je le crois il a mal quelque
part si vous étiez une arme ci est
énorme
nique ta mère mais avec pas chez sony et
si vous étiez une mort
enfin un truc bien horrible la tête dans
une baignoire
parce que veut on veut que je dise où je
veux mon mag auprès d'un truc ridicule
brouette je m'attends mourir pour savoir
d'accord oui mort qui sert la tête
aurait bla bla bla et on permet de
sourds ça franchement ça c'est pire que
de te brûler les pieds parce que parce
que le gaz ou des choses comme ça on
accorde un moment d'inconscience 6 8 kw
est là c'est vraiment c et on peut te
l'a serrée et le corps humain trop bien
fait cette affaire le monde est super
conscience ouais mais quand on te noies
ouais c'est que ce kung fu bu même ceux
qui savent pas ce que c'est après à ce
moment une même pièce
france soir si vous étiez de mort d'un
mois dans mon livre je cite une marque
est très belle à un moment il raconte la
mort de quatre cas qu'elle est très
belle passe qui venant de la morphine il
et il est en train de mourir et ça c'est
assez d'amour luxueuse en attend ils
demandent de la morphine le type on n'a
pas oublié non il y en a pas il dit
cette phrase extraordinaire dit tuez moi
sinon vous êtes un assassin
alors oui non à fait
si le portrait chinois ces sites étaient
une fleur jeu sera un mieux aux autistes
lentilles portrait chinois c'est des
choses qui sont plus noirs en général
attention vous êtes prêts
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bien si vous étiez un défaut c'est le
terreau défaut je serai ce sera un bon
jour une injure pas ce soir chéri j'ai
la migraine une maladie ben j'aurais la
bougeotte une perversion
ce serait de le maquiller avec une
poupée gonflable un vis à vis
j'ai pas se serait appelée ta femme par
exemple une trahison décès en silicone
ouais une arme une arme des talons
aiguilles
1 une cicatrice une une marque de rouge
à lèvres sur le bout de ma de ma cravate
un poison
ce sera une une compilation de julio
iglesias a volé femme un [ __ ] un
[ __ ] un [ __ ] ce serait un alcoolique
au volant oui parce que ce que ce que ce
que vous dites en fait c'est que vous en
voulez pas au monde entier en 9 71 tout
ça je suis planté tout ça aide
ce qui est terrible c'est les gens qui
se font plus terribles mecs qui passent
dans la rue laffitte ce fait est un type
qui sait me dont il peut carrément
identifier celui caputi sérieux relève
vous étiez un dictateur ce serait se
serait lolita de lolita manon si vous
étiez une torture ce serait je sais pas
moi condé complète ne une humiliation
une humiliation complique mon fauteuil
roulant ce serait bien dans la merde
un accident au ce serait de tomber
amoureux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà jean marie bigard les bouger ouais
si vous étiez un défaut la gentillesse
ouais mais c'est un super défaut ça on
n'est pas à l'abri d'ailleurs de la
gentillesse des autres si vous êtes une
injure allez tous vous faire [ __ ]
ça a le mérite d'être clair mais si vous
étiez une maladie une maladie je serai
peut-être la maladie ah oui je serai la
maladie de gilles de la tourette tu
connaisses et mardi j'ai vu ça l'autre
jour c'est extraordinaire si on leur met
qui parle normalement c'est comme un
tick tock je veux qu'on se paie et tout
d'un coup le mec sort une insanité quoi
ouais c'est monsieur charles avec lui
j'ai dit à thierry j'aime bien ton
émission va de sherbrooke que les cas là
mais il ya on voit pas assez souvent
laurent baffie twilight continue à
parler normalement mais aussi alzheimer
c'est pas mal
ouais d'ailleurs tu sais que robinson
crusoé sur la fin de sa vie il avait la
maladie d'alzheimer ah bon tu sais
comment ils appelaient vendredi
non l'autre jour
jean marie bigard si vous étiez un
accident je suis un accident mais oui si
vous étiez une perversion je suis une
perversion beau mais qui parce que ça
veut dire chaîne suisse et y ait une
guerre
je serai la guerre des boutons ce qu'est
la guerre maintenant su avec des boutons
marais et puis elle se fait
économiquement il des boutons tu vois
bien jk les propres soit disant vaisseau
fin de rencontre quand un mec sur un
bouton à bon père de famille dit bon
l'embargo continue l'embargo est il
appuie sur un bouton y tu as cru sur
3500 personnes par jour par exemple
l'embargo sur l'irak qui a tué un
million et demi de personnes dont cinq
cent mille enfants de moins de cinq ans
simplement toi ici et bien aligné toi ça
cent mille enfants toi là j'ai pas vu
beaucoup de minutes de silence pour ça
non mais un embargo ça tue à coup sûr et
puis bon ben voilà donc c'est la lèque
ce serait vraiment la guerre des boutons
situés une arme je serai excalibur si
j'étais une house déjà parce qu'elle
sait pas tirer pas tout le monde
comme d'hab il remarquer et situent ces
miettes on servir tu peux pourfendre un
certain nombre de groupes avec exclure
je savais que calibur wauquiez
bien sûr
si vous étiez une cicatrice cicatrices
la cicatrice de l'appendicite parce que
c'est pas loin de la salle des fêtes
si vous étiez un poison jeu sera une
femme
ouais
[Applaudissements]
allez go
tj doute en sommes à quatre ans quand on
en bouffe avec des amis je ne tourne
vers ma femme et j'ai dit tais toi toi
mal baisées et grâce à qui la veut dire
à toi chérie
bon alors puis ceux qui commandent
ah justement si vous étiez une [ __ ]
sera une chaîne genre béatrice dalle toi
ouais parce que j'adore béatrice abbas à
la question au contraire même s'il adore
super mais maintenant en plus en cause
on n'est pas ce que c'est non je dis
j'évite béatrice dalle parce que c'est
le type de fille qui est d'ailleurs de
cordialement détesté par les autres
femmes certainement parce que c'est vrai
que tu as envie de grimper dessus et tu
sais que tu vas jamais y arriver quoi
ils ont je suis très fantasmé league
si vous étiez un dictateur
charlie chaplin c était un assassin
rocco siffredi est ce que c'est une idée
de film
je sais que ce sera un serial buteur
mais qui tuerait des blondes à coups de
beats alors rechercherait l'atout de la
france là bas ça si vous étiez une
torture une torture
un truc pire que jean pierre foucault 1
chez pol je serai un vélo un vélo c'est
une torture la preuve les ils sont
obligés de prendre de la drogue pour
monde et y est c'est à dire que c'est
dur c'est quand même à vélo la sueur des
gonaïves et le truc r windows r
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et oui c'est le meilleur cas michel
drucker a mis en vente par michaëlle
jean
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est génial ça c'est devant le carré
blanc michel brûlé
lemaitre lui a rien demandé un mois bah
tu peux donner ce que tu veux un jeune
claudia n'ont peut-être pas mais non
mais qu'est ce que je vais te donner à
réfléchir autrement
et maintenant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
roche
voilà seven bells et wassila table que
je peux des caméras cachées soient les
caméras il le sait font michael alors
pour le micro je fais comment battu non
mais le slip c'est pas c'est pas
suffisant tiens tu sais tu sais tu sais
que depuis bercy
je ne quitte pas ses chaussures oui
parce que c'est elle qui sont entrés
devant les 13000 29 mai eh ben je donne
les chaussures et le sait le tribalisme
merci c'est bon michel blanc de plus la
chine et à toutes et bienvenue pour
nicole blanc
en question
vos missions
mais lui
[Applaudissements]
oh
bercy d'orly
là
en amical si tu sors pas de cabanes avec
moi
[Applaudissements]
je trouve ça vachement bien que gasquet
devrait d'abord il veut sortir de là
parce que mais qui lie à perpète ses
impressions de calais lille a pris 22
ans pour avoir tué six gonzesses et lui
pour un peu de shit il est à perpète
donc c'est si on arrive à faire bouger
ça et si tu y arrives et ben c'est
vachement bien parce que ça va faire
école
bah ouais il faudrait que chirac un peu
aussi un vas-y chaque écrivain jacques
un sit-in morts je serai une petite mort
c'est la petite mort ouais la petite
barque tu as vu dans les yeux de ta
femme comme il l'a fait jouir à coup en
69 sous marine
les avocats
en comparant la ligue 1
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si vous étiez un défaut un défaut
d'attention se rentrer sur scène la
braguette ouverte par exemple par
exemple si vous étiez une injure un fast
food en bord de mer une maladie la
sinusite une partie de mes cachets je
les donne pour la recherche pour
l'assainissement oui mais parce que
toutes les maladies importantes été
prises comme le sida ou moi j'essaie de
trouver une maladie en proportion que ma
notoriété
si vous étiez une guerre une guerre la
guerre de troie pour parce que voilà ce
que la guerre de troie n'aura pas lieu
s'il tient à vis le nooyi sme
le nuj isme c'est parce que c'est celle
arnouil non le mélangisme vous
connaissez ouais bien sûr un fétichiste
me voilà ce que lui et le nous y sommes
c'est une partouze où les gens viennent
déguisés en nouilles
ah oui non ça vient des états unis c'est
très simple moi j'en ai fait une
un très brillant coquillettes les
franchement je ne veux pas je me suis
éclaté c'est arrivé en france en janvier
2002 alors un petit peu patienter mais
il ya un truc qui va arriver aussi en
france à ce prix de l'acier le liban le
liban a été tué gémit il paraît que
c'est radical highway ce que moi je
cherche le moyen magique pour arrêter de
fumer parce que j'ai aucune volonté
il paraît qu'il faut un petit peu de
volonté et ça agit directement sur les
cellules du sang dépendant du thème du
tabac
pas de bouton rond dedans ni de nicotine
il ya le gaullisme qui va arriver en
france il ya le liban après ses 15 ans
médias via le terrorisme aussi
préparez vous bien si vous étiez une
arme tarte à la crème
un supplice chef opérateur sur un film
porno parce que tu en as fait 120
elle est oubliée ouais c'est vrai que
guillon oui si vous étiez une cicatrice
new york
jean majeau vous dit à chaud embêté
parce qu'il a été très brillant et moi
j'ai été très nul et non voulez vous
aussi vous dise pourquoi c'est parce que
je m'étais préparé soit des trucs comme
des préservatifs
qu'est ce que l'on pensé peu sucer ses
baisers quote part d une caméra c'est
aux gens dans le temps est ce que mon
français de sucer c'est tromper premier
ministre est là qu sur quoi vous
m'interrogez sur l'académie je suis
imprévisible jean d'ormesson
je lui ai vous avez été très bien puis
djamel vous a aidé et je suis gay marley
avec plaisir si vous étiez un dictateur
un dictateur l'audimat
ouais bonne réponse est non mais t'es
dictateur démissionnerait si vous êtes
une infirmité quelqu'un qui mémorise par
les prénoms
ouais mon père ils me donnaient des noms
de mes frères et le mien david bernard
stéphane et encore ça s'est amélioré
parce qu'avant on avait un chien qui
s'appelait pépettes
[Rires]
c'est avec quoi je vous signale que ça
s'acquiert ceux dont la saq est ce que
vous connaissez les prénoms avant et
puis tout à coup ils m'échappe mais le
vôtre où vous le mia ça va encore dire
qu'il est facile si vous étiez un
assassin à la salle andré est ce que
vous savez que quand l'un d'eux a été
condamné à mort à a tout à voir dernière
minute il ya un prêtre que lui voire et
qui lui a dit mon enfant pourrait vous
l'apporté les secours la religion est ce
que vous croyez à dieu ce que vous
croyez à une autre vie et l'envoie
répondu oh mon père est ce que vous
trouvez que c'est le moment de
plaisantes
si vous étiez un microbe microbes
le microbe c'est c'est difficile parce
que par exemple claudia schiffer grippe
et je n'embrasse way michèle alliot
marie en pleine santé publique est une
torture
une torture passé une nuit en copain
avec une fille sublime
ouais ça vous est déjà arrivé à tout le
monde
je promets je ne touche pas aux vrais
métallique qui me touchait pas
[Rires]
bienvenue si vous étiez une humiliation
l'humiliation à une fois j'étais c'était
dans un dîner j'étais très jeune à dîner
chez un copain et j'étais tellement gêné
d'être atteint avec les parents de mon
copain que je me suis mis à à caresser
le chien sous la table et à un moment
donné je me suis aperçu que c'était la
jambe de la mère de mon copain c'était
dans les années 80 il ya des des jupes
avec des deux les morceaux de laine
comme ça vous voyez quand vous
vieillissez vous croyez vous caresser la
jambe
dernière question stéphane c'est bien
stéphane je peux faire comme votre père
là vous n'êtes pas david le sujet est il
mort la mort de james dean à l'âge de
jeanne calment
[Musique]